[Music]
i got these two great tennis players
all we need
is a club
everything to go from prodigy to pro
race your hand serena venus williams
what you think
nobody's taking that bat
tennis takes expert instruction
it takes families with unlimited
financial resources
it's like asking somebody to believe
that you got the next two mozarts in
your house
venus and serena gonna shake up this
world
[Music]
yeah that's it there you go
they're not going to wimbledon like this
not with you and me on those raggedy
courts
we just got to stick to the plan we got
champions in other rooms
taught him almost
richard i'm impressed i think you might
just have the next michael jordan
oh no brother man i gots me the next two
let me ask you about something what do
you want out of this i know what your
dad wants but what about you well i went
to williamson as many times as anyone's
ever wanted you think you can do that
every american player got good following
this path we're going to do this a
different way
you pulled them out of juniors now you
pull them out of practice you do it
constantly i'm trying to look out for my
kids you're looking out for yourself
this is their life
you've got to let them decide
venus williams what you want let's show
all those people that i can handle
what's coming
[Music]
you are a champion
and the whole world know it
she played the best player on the planet
she can't beat her
but what if she do nobody
[Music]
i have never been more proud
in my whole life
you want to show them how dangerous you
are
let me see your dangerous face
that's your dangerous [ __ ] make some
dangerous noises
that's your dangerous face
okay don't do that for the people
[Music]
you